老師 剛看你8月的對帳單
賺了974萬
教一下你怎麼做的
喔 其實你要學會做期貨
你要學會判斷什麼
大盤
很多人連期貨是什麼
他都不知道
所以你要了解根本喔
結算是用
加權指數去結算的嘛
所以你要了解
大盤的方向
這一波不難啊
大家都會開車嘛 是不是
來 假設你從中部
要去北部的話
你要開高速公路嘛
MA5就是它的匝道方向嘛
所以你看
從這邊MA5是下彎
直到這一天站上 MA5
站上 MA 五代表什麼
我要飄向北方了嘛
MA5向上走走走..
欸！！
一路向上都不會轉彎嘛
當這一天它跌破匝道
吼 你怎麼開到南下交流道
代表什麼
你肯定要南下了嘛
這邊南下兩天
MA5還是下彎的
代表還是一個空方勢嘛
MA5從這天又站上
漲漲漲 漲到今天
今天盤中喔 哇
跟你講說多慘多慘
要崩盤了有沒有
但是你看
打到五日線
五日線又拉起來
MA 五它是上揚的
代表還是一個上升的趨勢啦
方向沒有轉變之前
你就不要太緊張
那我們說可以
搭配什麼方向呢？
季線
阿季呀嘛 是不是
阿季呀是MA60
現在是上揚
但是為什麼會有危險？
大盤的扣抵值
什麼叫扣抵？
下面有一個三角形 有沒有
大盤從今天往前推
一二三四五 #U)JQ#())(*&
數到60天
就是數到這一根
今天大盤扣抵的位置在哪裡？
在這一天 在6月5號
明天會扣抵到這一根
禮拜三扣抵到這邊
禮拜四扣抵到這邊
禮拜五扣抵到這邊
下禮拜一 下禮拜二
下禮拜三 下禮拜四 下禮拜五
下下禮拜一 下下禮拜二
下下禮拜二會扣到最高點
代表什麼意思
只要大盤的位置
比扣抵位置還要低
季線就會下彎
下彎就形成蓋頭反壓嘛
所以什麼時候
多方才會有機會？
扣到最高之後
它要開始往下扣嘛
接下來如果未來一直往下扣的話
只要大盤的位置
比扣抵的位置還要高（口誤
季線就會上揚
9月中下旬之後是往下扣
大盤除非再往下跌
它才會下彎嘛
大盤是往上漲或是走平就好
季線還是會上揚
所以9月中下旬
到10月初就是
大盤最好的上攻時機點
你現在要上攻可以啊
但是你看
它就是不想攻擊嘛
你現在可以
找出一個方向嘛
之前有講過一個叫
黃金切割率
這也是一個玄學啦
你要取最高點到轉折點
這波最高點是48218嘛
從這個48218
取到最低點39384
最高點到最低點 0-1
反彈就可以去算喔
0.382 0.5
0.618 0.809
接下來就是1
反彈至少要0.382
如果0.382都沒有過叫什麼？
弱勢反彈
你去看國巨
0.382都沒有 不會漲
就是這樣子
但是你看
它有沒有站上第一關
它漲到0.809
0.809是多少？
最高點多少？
46531有沒有過？
過不了
所以它拉回整理
現在就卡在0.5到0.809
一直上下震盪整理
就是這麼簡單
所以其實不難
啊如果你要再搭配
更玄學的叫
波浪理論
喔 這個就更神奇
但是講這個
一定會被人家炮轟
一個新手
假如只能看一兩個
你會推薦他用什麼？
第五章裡面的波段條件嘛
波段條件裡面的4招
你只要學會這4招
你就嚇嚇叫
哪4招？
破底翻 假突破 形態 背離
這四招
有條件你再去做
基本上不會錯得太離譜
做對的話是有機會大賺的
我們看期貨好了
60 K
這波就有一個什麼？
破底翻角開始出現了
然後出現什麼
W
W 可以怎麼樣
向上走滿足
你看這一波
有沒有等於向上這一波
欸 這個就很好玩了
今天出現什麼
假突破
選擇突破了
不能回頭
一回頭會怎麼樣
容易下跌
啊今天你看
最低點殺到這邊來
打到一個大形態的什麼
頸線 W 底
又開始反彈
所以你看
你要找到方向趨勢
其實就不難了
第五章的股票波段條件
其實只要用裡面的4種條件
做期貨就非常非常夠用了
我們過去很多學生
完全沒買過股票
遵守這4招的條件來買賣
成功靠股票跟期貨
存到他們的第一桶金
這全部共8種的進場條件
我都會在
線上直播講座中分享
點下方資訊欄連結
就可以免費報名
講座的名額有限
如果點連結進去
沒有看到場次
代表暫時額滿了
我是小王子
我們下次見